(audience clapping)
- All right, well do you wanna hear her?
You gotta sit down at
some point, you gotta sit.
That's amazing. Does that
happen like in Target?
Like--
- No, no.
- You just walk in and you are like,
"well thank you, I arrived, I did."
- Half the time, they
are like, "is that her?"
- That's always, they never--
- I've never, sweats and everything, yes.
- But, we're both from Texas.
You recently were in Texas again, right?
- [Selena] Yeah
- Because you don't live
there anymore, right?
- No, I have a house there for, you know,
if I wanna go see family and
stuff because I still do.
But, I've slowly moved my
family out here so it's working.
- Clever.
(laughs)
- But yeah, I just for some
reason I wanted to back
to my middle school, I wanted to go back
to my childhood home,
which I do often, and--
Oh yeah, that was me bothering the class.
(audience laughs)
And I got to just be there
and say, you know like,
I was here and I never ever
thought that I could be
where I am now.
It was just really neat to see.
And my teachers remembered
me and one of them
just ripped me, she was like,
"I remember she was like,
I'm gonna go do this movie.
I was like yeah, right.
She just wanted to lie
and get out of school."
- That was, I went back to my school.
I remember my algebra
teacher, Miss Tover, was like,
"who you gonna, how are
you gonna know what they're
doing with your money, if
you're gonna make all this money
when you're old."
I was like, "I'll pay someone
to do it and hope they
don't screw me over."
(laughing)
- [Selena] Exactly.
- I was like, and then I
saw her and I was like,
"still hoping!"
(laughing)
It was like, I don't know.
But you went to your childhood
home, is that kind of
special for you?
- [Selena] Yeah.
- Like where you grew up.
- It was so, well I try to go there often,
just because it's nostalgic for me.
And I've gone every year or so.
Well, there's me!
(laughing)
But I grew up there and
everything started from there.
So I actually got to knock
on the door and someone
was finally there, because
no one's ever there.
It was just this chilled
dude and he's like,
"yeah, come look around."
He was so unfazed that I was there,
He's like, "yeah apparently
you wrote on this wall."
He goes, "also there's a crib
in the garage if you want it."
- [Kelly] What?
- I was like, "my crib?"
He was like, "yeah."
I was like, "my crib is in your garage?"
He goes, "yeah."
I was like, "can I have it?"
He goes, "sure"
I'm like, he has all this stuff.
And I had written in the
closets that I was in love with
Cole Sprouse.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I am older
than you, who is that?
- Cole Sprouse was on "Sweet
Life With Zack And Cody".
- Okay, I know that, yes.
- And I was obsessed with that show.
And I thought we were
gonna be together, one day.
(laughs)
- Then I guest starred on the
show, but I kissed his brother
and I didn't get to kiss Cole.
(audience sighs)
- I always feel bad for y'all.
I hate acting so like, I
don't know how you do it.
- He was my first kiss.
- Like, you don't know where
their mouths have been.
Oh my gosh!
- Yeah!
(audience laughs)
- Your first kiss was
with a stranger and actor?
That's fine!
- On camera!
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- It was one of the worst days of my life.
- You know what, mine wasn't
acting and it wasn't camera.
Mine was horrible.
It was like he was searching
for something with his tongue.
It was, yeah.
- Oh gosh!
(audience gasps)
- I was like, "there's nothing in there,
it's just my mouth."
like, and I literally went
and spit in his bathroom,
it was horrible.
You said that this album
is your most honest album.
So why do you think so?
- Because I started so young,
there's a huge part of me
that didn't get a chance
to develop my identity in a
normal setting.
So when I was working with
Disney, it was the best time
of my life and I had a great
time, I had nothing but
good things to say.
But it was a bit more controlled.
There were certain things
that I was, you know,
kind of had to do and not maybe, go into,
like figuring out what my sound would be.
So I've constantly been
trying to make my music
better and better because, you know,
I know that people may
not think that I'm the
greatest singer but I
just worked my ass off and
I love, I really love
writing and creating.
And creating melodies and growing.
And I felt like this was my
chance to say all the things
that I wanted to say in that way,
which was talking about
relationships, and talking about
difficult times, or being vulnerable,
or being stuck in your head.
Because, you know, I can do that a lot.
But I wanted it to feel good.
You know, I wanted it to
feel like every word mattered
and you could feel it physically.
And I'm still in the studio actually now,
because I feel like it's
inspired me and I just
wanna keep going.
- A creative time, yeah.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- Ain't that funny, you make an album,
that always happens with me too.
I make an album and then
after I'm releasing it,
like right while I'm doing
it, I'm doing another one.
- [Selena] Yeah exactly.
- It always happens like that.
- I'm like, I don't just--
- But I wanna point something out because,
doing the voice especially,
has been really interesting
because a lot of people
always think, 'cause you said
"I know people might not
say I'm the best singer"
The best singer in the
world, talking to everyone
in the world right now, is not
the loudest, and is not the
"oh my God you've just sang
Whitney Houston" every time
you get.
The best singers in the world move you.
And that comes from all
different sounds and styles.
So like, from a singer to a singer,
it's beautiful what you
do and I love your record
and I love big, huge songs.
But I love singing your music,
it means something and it moves people.
So don't ever negate your
gift, because it's powerful.
- [Selena] Thank you.
(audience claps)
(audience cheers)
- That's what I wanted to say to that.
(audience clapping)
but whenever I first heard
"Rare" I was in a car
and I was listening to
Spotify or something.
And I was like, "what?"
And I knew it was you
'cause I got all your music"
but I was like, "what is this whole idea."
like, as a writer myself,
what a concept that nobody's
ever done.
- Thank you.
Like, I mean, why did
that, did that word just
stick out for you?
- Yeah, I felt like, you
know, that song actually
came into fruition four years ago so.
- Wow.
- It stuck with me throughout
creating this album
because, I like the kinda song that says,
"look, I'm not perfect."
You know, but I do know
that I deserve the best.
- I'm special though.
- Yeah, and I think that is
so, it's such an important
thing to say.
It's like, I need that.
You know, I've compared
myself to people for years
and if feel like I'm, you
know, sometimes get insecure
and I get, you know, I
go through normal things.
And it's just that word
means so much to me,
because that's exactly what it means.
It means that every single
person wasn't meant to be
like everybody else, kind of thing.
- Yeah.
- Like you were saying to
me, wow I guess I'm now
saying it back myself.
(audience laughs)
But it's true, you know,
you are each created to be
who you are meant to be,
and that's that, you know.
- And I think until you
believe that you are rare,
no one else will.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- And that's what I love about it.
It's an empowering anthem.
Like I love, I love, like
I told you in the room.
It takes a lot to get me on a treadmill.
And I'm like, "I've
gotta have a good record"
And I've been jamming your
record literally, just non-stop.
So it's a really great record.
But you also have a new beauty line,
and it's called "Rare Beauty"
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Rare Beauty.
(audience cheers)
- I cannot wait to try
it, 'cause I'm actually
highly allergic to a lot of makeup.
But what got you into the beauty world?
- At first off I had such
a connection with my fans,
and most of the time it's
talking about real things
that they're experiencing.
And when I wanted to do this
thing, I wanted to actually
create a lifestyle with it.
I wanted a line that was simple,
and that was hyper-allergenic.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
- And not tested on animals, nothing.
I wanted it to feel like
every girl can wear it,
whoever wants to wear it.
But you could also build coverage.
So it's simple stuff to
just help you know how to do
the go-to thing.
And it's beautiful and it's encouraging.
You know, I have so many
ideas for it to come,
where it can just be something powerful,
or people can feel good.
- Yeah, it is nice 'cause
I didn't grow up knowing
how to do makeup.
There's a lot of girls that
aren't, we're like tomboys
and like, didn't do that.
So, it's really cool.
- Yeah this is super easy,
- And you have such a huge
fan base of women too,
and I love that you're not
just about the aesthetics,
you're also about what's
inside that counts.
- [Selena] Yes.
- And that's super important.
- Thank you.
- Something super random.
I hear, true or false,
you're a fan of "Shark Tank"?
- Yes, I am.
- True!
- I am, that's very true.
- Yeah, how did you get in?
I know a lot of people
it's like, you either love
"Shark Tank" or you've never seen it.
It's like once you've seen it--
- One episode, it's a tattoo.
One episode and you're
never gonna go back.
- It's addictive.
- I'm just so, all of a
sudden I think I'm them.
I'm like, royalties, that's a good one.
Like I would just try to like chime in
as if I knew anything.
But I realized I've owned half the things
that were--
You guys probably owned half
the things they've created.
'Cause I just--
- [Kelly] Yeah, and I just don't know it.
- I don't, exactly.
It's been around for so
long that I have the sponge,
I got the comfy, I got the pillow.
(laughing)
- You're like that old
lady at home, on like,
online shopping.
- I'm like, gotta have that!
(laughing)
Definitely ordering that.
- I need that.
- Yeah, for some reason.
- So your other thing is, which is funny
'cause of our show today.
But another obsession is
"True Crime", you love,
like you love "True Crime"
so much you went to something
I didn't even know existed.
- Yes.
- Which is CrimeCon.
- Con. Yes.
- What do they do at CrimeCon?
- Okay, so.
They give us a real case and this case--
- What?
- Yeah.
So this case in particular
has been reopened.
You're getting to see the interviews and
the interrogation pages from 20 years ago.
Now we're interviewing the same people,
we, it's not my case.
- She's like, "I was leading."
- I was literally just leading, but no.
But it was really interesting.
Like, for going in to
see how they, I mean,
but I'm gonna be honest,
I'm not good at it.
I was like, "everybody did it."
(laughing)
I mean that's just what I said.
I was like, "no, no, no, he did it."
And they would say some more stuff,
I was like, "they both did it."
I was like, I just--
- Everyone is guilty!
- [Selena] Exactly,
exactly, because I was--
- If you get jury duty, don't show up.
- I know, I know, exactly.
(laughs)
- Everyone did it.
- It's just an interesting subject, yeah.